como cada mañana marco preparar sus
herramientas de trabajo computador
portátil cargador y sus auriculares este
ejecutivo de una multinacional
financiera en milán decidió dejar la
capital lombarda al final del primer
confinamiento nacional la primavera
pasada objetivo volver a sicilia su
región natal en el sur de la península
pero no es una secta que cartera la que
hacemos en milán tenía un apartamento
pequeño y oscuro sufrí mucho durante el
primer confinamiento allí fue incómodo
así que decidí irme y volver aquí donde
tengo a mis padres ya mis amigos
desde su regreso a palermo hace siete
meses marco cambió el metro por la
bicicleta de camino al trabajo porque
nunca ha dejado su trabajo en el norte
trabaja a distancia desde un espacio
coworking a pocos minutos de su casa
desde aquí coordina y supervisa un
equipo de ocho personas todos están en
milán
con mi última durante 15 días tuve que
acostumbrar a mi equipo a esta nueva
manera de trabajar juntos pero a
distancia pero como somos un equipo muy
joven acostumbrado a las herramientas
digitales la transición fue muy rápida y
no disminuimos nuestra productividad y
productividad desde la explosión de la
crisis sanitaria en italia este tipo de
oficinas compartidas ha estado
floreciendo en palermo roberto
administra este lugar que antes de la
crisis tenía 46 puestos de trabajo ahora
reducidos a unos 20 para asegurar el
distanciamiento social en los últimos
meses se ha llenado el cupo a moute
llamada 'the departed' y recibimos
llamadas todo el tiempo de gente que
busca un lugar para trabajar muchos son
jóvenes que trabajan para el norte la
forma de ver ese trabajo está cambiando
la pandemia está acelerando la
comprensión del trabajo inteligente y el
trabajo en equipo smart working
y valiosas herramientas para los
empleados en la época de la pandemia
según una encuesta reciente desde la
primavera pasada casi 100.000
trabajadores han abandonado el norte del
país para instalarse en el med su giorno
las regiones del sur de la península que
están seriamente atrasadas en su
desarrollo al impacto extremo toro y
levante
el impacto de este fenómeno podría ser
significativo porque el nuestro horno
podría recuperar una mano de obra muy
productiva personas con títulos en
sectores innovadores y son ellos los que
en los próximos años podrían construir
un nuevo camino para el desarrollo de
metros hornos para los sicilianos el
regreso de esta población de
trabajadores plantea una esperanza la de
reducir la brecha entre el norte y el
sur de italia es bueno que los jóvenes
hayan vuelto traen riqueza y experiencia
del norte es positivo contrarrestar la
fuga de cerebros son una nueva energía
vital para nuestra sociedad siciliana y
para el sur en general
ante el crecimiento del fenómeno se creó
una asociación para facilitar el regreso
de los trabajadores objetivo solicitar
apoyo logístico a las instituciones esta
mañana elena y marco se reúnen con el
alcalde de un municipio a unos 100
kilómetros al este de palermo en el que
planea en abrir una empresa pública
señor alcalde buenos días buenos dias
por favor siéntese
estamos aquí para que nos actualicen
sobre los avances esta mañana los
técnicos tienen que venir a instalar la
fibra dentro del edificio y tenemos una
buena conexión a internet medios de
transporte conectados a aeropuertos
estaciones de tren para hacer el viaje
más rápido y también el establecimiento
de espacios de trabajo compartidos y el
trabajo para el alcalde de la ciudad es
una oportunidad para darle energía a
esta ciudad de 4600 habitantes y luchar
contra la desertificación que amenaza a
toda la región
[Música]
queremos convertirnos en una ciudad de
referencia para los recién llegados
queremos ofrecer a estos jóvenes unas
condiciones óptimas no solo para venir
aquí por poco tiempo sino también para
hacer que quieran establecerse aquí de
forma permanente longa así que para
atraer a estos jóvenes trabajadores el
municipio ha puesto a su disposición
estos hermosos locales con una vista
impresionante del mediterráneo este
edificio alberga al museo de cerámica
una tradición local de ahora en adelante
servirá para una doble función antes mi
vista era la del colega que trabaja
delante de mí en el espacio abierto de
la multinacional para la que trabajo en
milán ahora miro hacia arriba y veo las
islas eolias
un paisaje que inspira así como el
marcado aumento del poder adquisitivo de
estos trabajadores incomparables con el
que tenían hasta hace poco en el norte
todo lo cual es bueno para una mejor
calidad de vida y para disfrutar el
suave invierno del sur de italia